the jurogan experience i really enjoyed
when we did that
i mean it was a whole different yeah but
like not even the challenge aspect i
mean that was cool too but getting into
something that i didn't really do before
and i i do miss it i do like i like the
feeling of
completing one of those passes
yeah we we uh got to get bert on the
sober october train this year we can't
miss this one he needs to get sober i'm
down
because i want to see
i mean he's so much more of a drunk than
he's ever been before
right wouldn't you agree he's out of
control he's out of control what happens
is he uh you know it's not unlike i
think anybody that maybe tours is that
his wheels fall off on tour i mean you
know that happens to a lot of people you
get home you get grounded all right
and he but he tours a lot so what
happens is you know the party guys on
the road it's to be a [ __ ] party yeah
he put a post on the instagram he texted
me to telling me about it he's like i'm
going to lose weight i'm going to do
this i've got my goals and this is
this
and then uh he goes but i'm back on the
road in two weeks i'm like [ __ ] yeah
you ain't doing [ __ ] you're gonna have
getting jacked this month he's gonna
have money one hard workout and he's
gonna be really tired and he's like i
deserve a drink
there's a video of him that he put up on
his instagram and it's i think
it's from him on the podcast on this
podcast talking about how much he loves
drinking i'm never going to quit
drinking always i love it i love it i
love when someone says he gives a couple
of speech he has a couple of those
i know what it was from it was from some
it's called the sunday podcast yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's that's it yeah where he
does this really yeah he's done on this
one too but on that one it
yeah he he does it almost it feels like
a coach right right right yeah half time
you're going to win this [ __ ] chance
he's evangelizing yeah yeah
he does this thing sometimes where he's
totally serious where we'll be together
i'm like how you doing like we just
first sat down how you doing he's like
good good i've been drunk in a while
feel good gotta go like when's the last
time you drank he'll go
tuesday i'm like that's not that long
ago that's two days ago yeah
drinking yeah
i will never quit drinking
i will always make sure that i can keep
my body healthy enough so that i can
always drink i love seeing a sunrise
with a cocktail seeing a sunset with a
cocktail having friends walk into your
house with a bottle of wine getting on a
plane can i get you something double
jack on the rocks lots of rocks
i love
the moment someone says hey we should
get a drink and you and you're not
supposed to that feeling it's like a
first kiss you don't get that first kiss
kisses when you're married you get to
have those first drinks at a brunch
someone goes should we do mimosas and
then the waiter goes actually we have
bottomless mimosas and you're like
this is gonna be the best day ever
dude you just hyped me the [ __ ] up
speech yeah yeah that's pretty
inspirational i should speak at aa
meetings
he's crazy but it's also yeah he's built
different
he really is actually he really is a
[ __ ] hell of an athlete if he wasn't
a drunk that's the total 100 truth like
when you played him tennis
[ __ ] unbelievable yes
it wasn't even here's the thing
he didn't really prepare for that
and he also showed up hungover and with
beers on him
like in a in his hoodie pouch
and i was like
are you okay he's looking pretty
hungover oh
what it was too because he actually has
um he played he was a really good
baseball player right he has really good
hand-eye coordination
um
and that his serve was
i'm not joking is phenomenal really his
serve was phenomenal for somebody that's
also not actively playing
and he could do things like you do kick
serves and like he could put spin on it
and he was serving impressive
impressive for anybody who plays tennis
but especially for someone who's not
even playing all the time yeah
[Laughter]
let me see this is like give me some
volume let me see if he's like nope
didn't like that one well he's maybe but
this is like him still figuring it out
right that's that's a light that's not
an example did we just start this match
off with an apes
he gets
so much and this is my [ __ ] gay sir
hold on
this is like
okay this is really bad but
i can't play tennis at all so
this was impressed
when when you see him actually
serve next
kids around
this is so i'm sure horrific to watch
but
it's so bad i mean this is like watching
two blind people [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
when he uh when he got after it i guess
that didn't have it there um
but yeah so anyway i had i had a tennis
coach there a like a really good player
and after the match
he's like dude he goes i'm sorry because
he coached me
and i go what he goes he has a legit d1
college serve
and i go what he goes yeah that is
[ __ ]
really impressive i had no idea wow he
would have that but he does have he has
athletic gifts for sure he does if he
wasn't a fat [ __ ]
if he wasn't a fat [ __ ] he'd be a hell
of an athlete the only actually you know
that the thing that would completely
change that guy is it's obvious but it's
his it's his caloric intake right like
he yes he's had a surplus every day
right it's surplus food a surplus drink
if he was like i if you told him you
have to
cut this out right your life's gonna
you're gonna die
he would [ __ ] look unbelievable like
the weight loss challenge when you guys
the first sober october we did was just
a weight loss channel but even that he
did it the bert way right which is like
he crammed two weeks out he's like i'm
gonna starve myself like that's how he
did it he didn't do it like you know and
did he even starve himself i think he
just dehydrated yeah he dehydrated
himself he probably skipped a bunch of
deals he has a skinny formula which is
what yeah he goes you want you want to
be skinny
yeah because what you do is you drink
you take a xanax what yeah he's like you
sleep and then you wake up skinny
because you haven't eaten in like 15
hours i'm like yeah you could just be
awake and not eat
[Laughter]
you know what a bizarre way of handling
it yeah it's just his mind man oh god
such a kid thank god he's a comic right
mm-hmm imagine if that poor [ __ ] was
like some salesman somewhere yeah just
be hating life waiting to get drunk oh i
could see him totally
working at like a tackle shop you know
it's like somewhere like you need bait
you need some
get some worms here for you and he would
just be
tipping one back on the job and yeah
it's fine he works at a bait shop you
know maybe maybe they'd fire him who
knows you put the worms where the
[ __ ] lures are supposed to be yeah
he's just yeah there's like there's
certain people that you can't imagine
them being anything other than comics
yeah for sure he is he is our john daly
oh yeah for sure that's definitely who
he is yeah that's our john daly but it's
but what i worry is that it's like so
attached to his persona right he has
that thing
it's not uncommon where he goes i don't
want to disappoint people
they're here to see the machine they
want to have a drink
they want to party with me and he's not
he doesn't want to let them down you
know
well he'll let them down when he dies
yeah that's going to be a letdown that
would suck the thing is like you can't
live long like that yeah i know nobody
lives long like that no
you you live but
i know you're you're in a weird race
with
obviously he has great genetics he does
he does
so for drinking his genetics are
fantastic yeah they really are because
he doesn't even when he's really drunk
he's pretty [ __ ] coherent there's
times where i didn't know
and then also it's revealed he's like
i've had
85 drinks yeah
he's like i drank like these two bottles
of whiskey and 45 beers i'm like what
and then i'll be like oh yeah he's like
check this out and he takes clothes off
i'm like oh okay like now but i didn't
know a moment ago when we were talking